[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday October 4th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
for more than a year White House
officials have been negotiating with
Executives from Tick Tock they've been
talking about possible measures to
prevent data that the video sharing
company collects on its millions of
American users from being shared with
the Chinese government now Tick Tock
which is owned by the Chinese Tech Giant
bite dance denies that it would share
user information with Beijing but
lawmakers particularly Republicans have
pushed back on that and it's expected
that if the GOP takes control of one or
both chambers of Congress after the
midterms they'll push for hearings on
the issue
sources say that backdrop is adding a
sense of urgency to the White House's
conversations with Tick Tock joining us
to discuss all of this is our reporter
John McKinnon hi John thanks for joining
me hi so what is the Biden
administration's approach to getting a
deal here Ben
the first step the administration took
was to basically Stand Down from some
very aggressive efforts that were
undertaken during the Trump
Administration to either shut down Tick
Tock in the U.S or force it to change
its ownership structure so that it would
be owned by a majority U.S group The
Biden Administration
believed that that was legally
indefensible and thought that there were
probably better solutions to be had and
so they said that they would set out to
reach some conclusions on how to do that
it's taken longer I think than a lot of
people expected for them to come to
those conclusions and reach those deals
although all the signs are that they are
heading towards some agreement
around the end of the year the early
part of next year with Tick Tock and
there's also some indication that
they're going to reach a broader
understanding and issue some orders
about how to deal with the the problem
overall
what kinds of safeguards then should we
expect if a deal is reached with Tick
Tock the administration in what's called
cypheus This is an intergovernmental
group task force that deals with
security issues in
foreign investments in the United States
the indications are that they are going
to require Tick Tock to house the data
that it collects in the U.S and that
they're going to probably Identify some
trusted third-party and likely to be
Oracle to basically monitor the data
flows and monitor how the data is
handled you mentioned that the deal has
taken a little bit longer than some
people expected what have been the
hurdles to getting it done it's pretty
complicated as I understand it to
work out exactly how to achieve these
levels of safety that the US would like
to achieve and it's a very difficult
problem to figure out how to keep this
data safe when the US is having such a
difficult time you know maintaining the
safety of a lot of other data there's
also political considerations that
they've had to deal with some people say
that if they reach a deal before the
midterm elections that might make the
administration and Democrats more
vulnerable politically to these attacks
because it would just be in the public
eye a little bit more so there there's
some technical issues and there are some
perhaps political issues
so that's what you've heard from people
who are familiar with these discussions
what have we heard from Republicans
about these efforts you mentioned
there's political tension there are
certainly some Republicans that are very
much more hawkish on China even than the
administration and would say that Tick
Tock for instance needs to be owned by a
us-based entity which was what the Trump
Administration was trying to achieve and
there are certainly others that say that
the administration needs to make tick
tocks sever all ties with China and not
use any of its algorithms or have any
connection with China and tick tock's
response to all this are they talking
about the deal or about these
accusations
Tick Tock is trying not to comment on
the specifics of these negotiations with
cepheus but they certainly have offered
many assurances that they are not
sharing Americans data with the Chinese
government and Tick Tock is really I
think in a little bit of a difficult
position because I think that they are
perhaps not as trusted by the US
government as they would like to be and
they're frankly not as trusted by the
Chinese government as they would like to
be
unusual is this situation where the U.S
is trying to kind of step in and set up
these safeguards on one hand it's a
little bit unusual because the power of
social media platforms is a new problem
that the US is confronting but on the
other hand the US has had lots of
experience with foreign investment in
the U.S and has had ways of dealing with
National Security risks associated with
foreign investment in the US for a long
time and some of the measures that they
will probably implement including some
of the oversight measures the the board
of overseers that they'll probably
require Tick Tock to create with a lot
of U.S citizens and U.S National
Security Experts on it those are
measures that they've done in the past
with other U.S entities that have been
owned or controlled by foreigners but
again the circumstances here are
somewhat new and unique and very hard to
figure out like how do you protect all
this data this massive amounts of data
that are collected on the internet and
are so easily transferred
all right so what do we expect to happen
next then at some point I think probably
after the midterm elections but maybe
before Congress really gets cranked up
in January they'll probably be an
announcement of a cepheus
National Security agreement with Tick
Tock and at that point Tick Tock will
have some of the concerns of all of this
lifted off their shoulders and we'll go
from there
all right that's our reporter John
McKinnon thanks for joining us John oh
thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]